[Music]
it all happened so fast
[Music]
there was a solar flare
[Music]
goodbye crops and food goodbye
everything
it's a super fire
in our own solar system
a 100 micro tesla wave of radiation that
would destroy our ozone layer
killing every living organism on the
planet gives advice go there are these
people called preppers you ever heard
about preppers no okay these are guys
that are planning and gals planning for
the end of the world and the
civilization
preppers yeah they preppers right so one
of the things they're worried about in
addition to a global pandemic that would
never happen though but but something
that could happen is a solar storm a
carrington event a solar mass ejection
um first of all what are those things
should we worry about them is that
overblown how would you personally
prepare is this something that you're
really worried about so the sun is uh
explosive in its surface activities at
the at the micro scale and large scale
and the larger scale explosions
are known as flares
if it's contained because there's a
sufficiently strong magnetic field
overlying the magnetic fields that break
apart and
give their energy to the matter that you
know would otherwise go and a lot of
that energy does excitations and
ionizations which results in
what you assume it's fully ionized but
excitations will result in light being
emitted but then if there isn't a
sufficiently strong overlying magnetic
field just burst out and if it's pointed
at the earth it's coming at us and you
know
it carries magnetic fields
and so if the magnetic field of the
material coming from the sun in that
coronal mass ejection is opposite in
direction to the magnetic field of earth
then you have your worst case scenario
carrington event type event and so what
happens is the earth magnetic field just
gets collapsed down
right and so it gets penetrated and the
earth's magnetic field
some of those field lines reconnect
themselves just like what happened on
the sun to trigger that flare
and that sends charged particles
streaming down and hitting our uh
atmosphere which ionizes crates as the
northern lights but when you have
changing magnetic fields right so i
always ask my students in you know how
do you create what creates electric
fields electric charges changing
magnetic fields what creates
magnetic fields
moving electric charges changing the
electric field so that changing magnetic
field in our magnetosphere creates
electric fields which move
currents through our power lines and
could destroy
um
satellites our power grid you know it it
could be really bad but i think what we
should be more concerned with is what's
happening with the earth's magnetic
field the earth's magnetic field serves
as our shield and our magnetic field
from time to time flips
and at the midpoint of that flip the
earth is not as protected from the solar
wind particles radiation as otherwise
would be
now this is not something that happens
in a day right or a year right you know
it
but uh right now the sun is weak if you
look at the
peaks and the maxima as it has more and
more flares and this sort of thing each
peak is an equal there's a cycle they
get stronger and weaker so they've been
getting weaker so our sun today in terms
of its surface activity
it's weaker than average
so it's when you have a solar maximum
when the maxima are near the big
maxima that you can get events like this
and we don't have to worry about that